حقيقه هي مشكله كبيره انا الان ساحاول ان
التقي باحد الاشخاص الذي يقيم هنا في هذه
الخيم كان ايضا يقيم في نورداغ سوف اساله
عن يعني اولا باسل باسل اسمه باسل باسل
اول شيء الحمد لله على السلامه الله يسلمك
يا رب انا اول شيء بدي اسالك يعني
اكيد
وقت الزلزال كانت لحظات كتير عصيبه وبتخوف
ممكن تحكي لنا يعني وقت اللي صار الزلزال
كيف قدرتوا تطلعوا من البيت ويعني والحمد
لله رب العالمين تهربوا من هاي من هذه
الزلزال ايه الحمد لله والله اول ما صار
الساعه اربعه او حسينا عليه انا مباشره
شلت بنتي وقلت لعيلتي نطلع بره مباشره
ودخلت على الاهلي طلعته الحمد لله طلعنا
لبرا كان الجو ماطر وفي بيوت مهدمه والحمد
لله
الله نجانا بعد ما الحمد لله نجته او
هربتو من موضوع الزلزال وين قعدتوا اول
يوم ويومين والله اول يوم ما في محل تروح
عليه ما في انا في عندي هاي السياره باركت
فيها والله ضليتوا باركين بالسياره اول
يوم اول يوم كم شخص بركي من السياره خمسه
خمس اشخاص طول اليوم طول اليوم انا
بالسياره اسبوع كامل
وعيلتك انت وعيلتك اسبوع لهذا الاسبوع الي
اسبوع كامل باركنا بالسياره طيب وحاليا ما
عندك خيمه الحاليه الحمد لله طلعتلي خيمه
وطلعت لاخوي هاي الخيمه انا اليوم راح
انتقل على خيمتي
اه يعني انتم اليوم راح تنتقل على خيمه
بعد اسبوع
هاي السياره طبعا هذه السياره التي
تشاهدونها هذه السياره كانت سكن عائله
لعائله لمده اسبوع كما نشاهد الان
سينتقلون الى خيمه قد الخيمه مين من افاد
من الافات الخيمه من هيئه الطوارئ
والكوارت التركيه طيب بعد الخيمه قديش
متوقعين تقعدوا بالخيمه بعدين وين راح
تروحوا والله الله اعلم نحن ما فينا نروح
على محل نظلنا نضل باركين بالخيم طب حاليا
النور داق تقريبا مهدمه يعني قسم كبير من
المباني مهدم وفي قسم اخر غير صالح للسكن
بيتك فيك ترجع تسكن بالبيت اللي كنت قاعد
فيه بيتي ما فيني اسكن بيه بيتي كلياته
وطقطق وشخشخ حيطان وما عاد ينسكن فيه بيتي
صاير ثلاث طوابق انا بارك بالارضي الحيطان
كلياتها غير صالح السكن
طيب لا يعني راح تضل قاعد في الخيمه
قبل ما تيجي على نور او تنتقل على نور
ضاغو وين كنت مقيم انا كنت مقيم مخيم
الاصلاحيه اه يعني هلا حنرجع من
من الخيمه اللي كنا فيها لا خيمه حاليا
تدمر
البيت هاي اراده الله
لا اله الا الله لاحق مع الاعتراض الحمد
لله على السلامه هذا اهم شيء وان شاء الله
شدوا وبتزول وازمه يعني ان شاء الله ما
بتطول تفرج ان شاء الله من الله ان شاء
الله شكرا شكرا كثير باسل كما تابعتم يعني
حقيقه المعاناه لم تنتهي فقط ليست هناك
معاناه فقط تحت الانقاض لاشخاص عالقين تحت
الانقاض واشخاص مع الاسف فقدوا ذويهم هناك
معاناه للاحياء الذين تمكنوا من الفرار
والنجاه في انفسهم وبعائلاتهم كما شاهدنا
وكما سمعنا عائله سوريه كانت تقيم لمده
اسبوع في هذه السياره التي توجد خلفي
وسينتقلون الى خيمه في هذه الظروف الجويه
الصعبه